so if you'll recall from our last lesson
we had created a method that set up all
of the appropriate properties with our
GPP sign-in object and created all the
appropriate delegate methods but we
hadn't actually called the method that
sets anything up or for that matter done
anything to sign the user in so let's do
that now we're going to go back into our
code and let's add a view today ode
method and we'll say super viewdidload
and then we can initialize this gpp sign
an object and then we can take this
shared instance and call authenticate
and this is basically the call that
tells our sign an object ok now let's
attempt to sign in the user so let's try
this now see what happens Hey look at
that we're set right into our dialogue
now before we go on let's take a look at
this URL here i'm going to select all of
course turns out this doesn't actually
select all let's go from here all right
now i'm going to copy this and let's
open up a random text file here and
paste this in and we got this giant URL
but let's break this up by the URL
arguments and take a look at this thing
does this look kind of familiar to you
this URL looks pretty similar to the one
we had in our presentation remember this
one we went to accounts google com we
set the client ID we set the scope and
we said a redirect URI well now let's go
back and look at our URL and you can see
here we have a scope we have a client ID
and we have a redirect URI there's a few
are the things that we've added here
this response type code means give me
back a one-time code this line basically
specifies the user's language this state
variable is used to help deter
cross-site forgery requests and this GPS
DK basically just says that the request
came from the Google+ SDK version 13 but
look at that this giant URL you pretty
much know what's going on we're saying
hey Google here's our client ID this is
our guest my number application we're
asking for the AA / game scope and when
you're done send it back to calm google
gets my number colon slash 0 op to call
back look at that we're now able to make
sense of this giant URL so now let's go
back to our simulator here and scroll
down and I'm going to click accept now
at this point it redirects back to our
application which is good right because
that's what we specified in our redirect
URI go to com google guess my number
however if we were to take a look at our
console output in xcode we don't see
anything we didn't get to this finish
with auth error handler and the question
is why not well that's because while
Mobile Safari does correctly redirect
back to our application our application
does nothing to handle that URL it just
kind of gets sent to us and we ignore it
so we need to do something about that
and this is something we do within our
app delegate so go over to your app
delegate and let's import Google+ /
google plus h and we're going to add
another method here we're going to add
application openurl source application
annotation this is basically the method
that gets called when your app
receive some sort of URL and is asked by
the system hey can you handle this it
returns yes if it's able to properly
handle it and returns know if it says I
don't really know what to do with this
thing now it turns out this method is
pretty simple because the Google+
library includes its own method that
does most of the heavy lifting for you
so first just in case actually you're
curious let's add in a little NS log
that shows the URL that we received so I
have received the URL to handle we can
call your L absolute string and then
we're just going to call the class
method gpp URL handler handle URL source
application annotation so the URL here
is URL source application is source
application and annotation is annotation
so we put the cynic additional we're
basically checking with Google+ and
saying hey does this look like a URL you
can handle if it does we return yes
otherwise we'll return now in case
you're saying to yourself hey that's
extra code why not just say return this
the answer is that this might work if
the only URL you are ever going to check
against is one sent from google plus but
in reality there might be urls you're
going to want to handle so more likely
than not there might be another else if
here and another else if and and so on
before you finally returned now so
that's why we rode it that way so now we
can run this and let's see what happens
again we're taken to the guest my number
application I click accept we get
redirected back to our application and
look here we've got a whole bunch of oo
auth information here in our log you can
see the URL we received and this code
equals blah blah blah blah blah this is
our one-time use code that the system
received it then exchanged that for a
bearer token and since everything worked
as planned our gpp sign an object called
finished with auth error and in this
case our auth is a GTMO ought to
authentication object that includes in
access token a refresh token and our
one-time use code along with an
expiration date and our error here is no
because we're a niche no errors so look
at that we received our bearer token
from the system and we've successfully
signed the user in of course it turns
out I still kind of lied to you we
signed the user in but we just did it by
calling authorized during viewdidload
this isn't the greatest user experience
you don't want your player taken to an
oauth2 dialogue before he or she has
even had a chance to you know see your
games title screen so we really are
going to add a sign-in button to
initiate the sign-in process and really
honest this time we're going to add it
in the next lesson have I ever lied to
you before so stick with me sign-in
button is coming next